here at quarter digital we try to keep
ourselves on The Cutting Edge of
technology and that means The Cutting
Edge entertainment in this case we've
tried to invent a new game show using
all this cool new AI art generation
tools out there what's up Wes what's up
so we've invited Wes and everybody else
here today because you know I figured
all my buddies needed a break I figured
we needed some time to laugh and you
might too so here's the idea we're going
to have a king of the hill combat round
here where you get a funny prompt and
two people compete to make the funniest
image in two minutes they're gonna be
using a bunch of different tools
mid-journey stable diffusion Dolly to
whoever has the funniest image stays up
as king of the hill and the other
Challengers rotate through until one of
them takes the crown
one twist
then you'll put that word first ideally
it's just a word or phrase that you
think will completely transform any
image I don't know about you guys but
I'm gonna write down my prompt my only
disclaimer here is that the image that
you will see that may or may not be
slightly offensive to you was generated
not by us but by an AI so that is not
our responsibility
are you guys ready to do some art
battles yes yes all right let's get on
first prompt is
this child was expelled from
kindergarten for obvious reasons
timer starts now these guys better
impress us because this is the first
round and we're hungry for some comedy I
don't know these are all oh boy I don't
know what I'm thinking like I just got a
bunch of pictures 30 seconds
I'm expecting razor blade lips Pockets
full of candy canes and different
gumdrops Pockets full of pistols all
right I went to a much different School
four three two
I'm feeling good I'm feeling good I got
I got a good one right at the end
choose your side choose inside
and Sam is the clear winner
all right Sam gets the point the face
Tabs are premium
tattoos are on this side
uh I'm surprised I didn't go too crazy
with that one that was just like
run-of-the-mill once again it's all
about obvious reasons so kept it obvious
Dean is up next to face Sam your prompt
is an Amazon propaganda poster for
employees to behave
all right and Jan hit him with the Trap
card Sam very experienced very
experienced prop Master Dean also
exceptionally experienced perhaps the
underdog in the situation but the fact
that Sam has a trap card played against
him is also gives me a little bit of
pause but is that is that gonna make it
even more successful it could 30 seconds
so stressed I I think Dean has the edge
because of that coat he's just looking
so thick how is there so much meat under
there I'm a little worried that I'm not
going to be able to generate something
funny in time two one
I need to pick a side pick a side I know
it's a debatable it's the battle we need
a winner man
Dean takes it
yeah what was the Trap card satanic of
course because it's jam and you know
what led to Europe Satan
Jan is up next against Dean influencers
are going crazy for this new plastic
surgery procedure
oh
[Music]
Jan is so deep in the AI in Layton space
oh I've been waiting my whole life to
take down that little thick boy
[Laughter]
Dean's feeling good Dean's feeling good
it's making him more powerful
all right no more prompting
all right Dean takes it yeah
it's a you get a built-in heel I gave
you body horror and you went for a flare
yeah
[Music]
Nick is up next against Dean ancient
Egyptian painting that they didn't want
to put in the history book
oh no no
all right Wes coming in with the track
let's Dean deal with it let's go
they already don't put a lot in American
history book so no stressed what's
happening he's falling apart 30 seconds
30 seconds oh I had a bad word I had a
banned word
I chose the wrong tool I think I think I
chose the wrong tool already oh Dean
thinks he's ready
not even milk in it two one I got
something at least I got something
huh
oh
it's unanimous Nick
[Applause]
what is that he's got a giant freaking
dong dude
look at this no no no it's definitely
this one
dude Ann West gave me a freaking donut
did Dean really convincing everybody all
of a sudden all right Dean takes them in
yes
you can't win them all you can't win
them all once you soak up all the
details it's the clear winner
the next comp is the poster for a gritty
R-rated reboot of Shrek
he stacked it up he helps me so much
we've all been waiting for a Shrek for
years and years that's gritty that's
real that's action-packed so I'm hoping
for some big results from this one Dean
is becoming AI slowly
I have a minimum viable product we'll
see what we get 30 seconds
yeah
I got it I feel super confident in mine
I feel like there is now a bias against
me because I'm the king a poster for a
gritty R-rated reboot of Shrek
thank you
choose your side I hate this this
doesn't look much like a poster like
here you have the title it's called War
all right Fender dethrones Dean
I'll be taking my trophies here
the next prop is how Willy Wonka managed
to capture so many Oompa Loompas this
was last time you beat me after my
streak I think I'm gonna give you this
guy thank you this just only helps me a
few minutes I'm feeling pretty confident
right now I have an intense imagination
smile fool you yeah that man is dark
uh the Trap card I feel like it really
screwed Fenner up which is my goal two
one
[Applause]
unanimous Wes is gonna stay on the chair
here we go guys the championship starts
Jesus Christ doing extreme sports I
don't know if I'm offended or not
I mean he did some extreme endurance
activity
no trap cards this round so it's intense
imagination at the end of the day we've
never seen Jesus look like this on the
cross that's all I'm gonna say I think
that this is hilarious
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's doing a pole vault I've never seen
somebody get Dynamic motions
Wes stays on the crown Wes is staying
talking to the next
despite its long history of Human Rights
abuses this country has now become a
stunning Utopia West
oh and he's throwing a trap card on top
of him
we got lots there's lots of options of
countries with long histories of Human
Rights abuses I'm not too experienced
with AI generated images this thing up
here can create some real nightmare
scenarios
[Laughter]
it's the Utopia of sand Sandy
and this year's the perfect future it's
utopian it's America
Austin yes
The Last of Us episode three but with
Bert and Ernie
Bert and Ernie they're doing most of the
sexy lifting themselves
okay now I'm scared I'm real scared I'm
glad I got a lot of pressure going on
I'm really gonna just rate this by how
much chess hair they can get into this
see this that's Ernie
I'm thinking of Santa's perfect yeah
that was hard because I I got four
rejected I had to do it four times it
did underwear no shirt no clothes
baby ball a new intense full contact
sport played by exclusively by pregnant
women the two ogs going up against each
other once again I need to see a
pregnant woman tackling another pregnant
woman does one of the pregnant women
have to give birth and does that become
the ball I think the full contact nature
of it a couple babies pop out it's
inevitable it's inevitable I'm feeling
pretty good yeah it's hard to decide
though oh yeah I gotta I I got a good
prompt five four three
[Applause]
[Music]
all right baby ball
she might have been pregnant at the
start again
look my image speaks for itself that's
all I have to say are you on that side
Sam gets it Sam gets it ah that was
tough
all right Dean you're up and Sam and
Dean have the same amount of wins at
this time
[Music]
oh wait come on
another trap card
yeah each of them have two trap cards
going in two comic book cover for the
action-pack new series Helen Keller here
in Louisville see no evil I think with
all these trap cards played we're gonna
see which contestant embodies Helen
Keller's mentality the most that's gonna
be what makes them win here I don't know
if there's much room for Creative
interpretation on this one so I'm
curious to see how these artists can
twist it around it's interesting though
I've noticed that mid-journey stable
diffusion and Dolly have all been pretty
well represented in the results here the
these these two have really five seconds
three two one
[Music]
so as soon as I typed in curly hair
woman it just they only came out as like
beautiful women and I couldn't move it
at all I don't know I mean wait a minute
it does say comic book cover that's a
that's a novel right there it's a
romance novel dude this is a super it
says comic action-packed where's the
action do you read Comics like it
doesn't need to be like zany it can be a
dramatic like what it feels like one of
those like Dark Horse comments like of
Neil Gaiman or vertigo like one of those
cool like greedy Comics that's this yeah
oh yeah by the way I had laptop Jonathan
I have no excuse those are way harder
there's a little bit to being a prompt
Master it's about knowing the words that
get you to the result as quickly as
possible
Capital right the board game
you believe Sam surpassed me but Sam is
a very very funny guy
three two one nice boom Capital right
the board game
[Music]
this looks more like the capital right
that's just like a beautiful tilt shift
photograph
yeah Sam Sam takes it God damn it
Sam says well I'm sorry yeah I know and
it wasn't even that great of a win I
think I may have to try the Dethrone Sam
here
this is my chance to get a win oh yeah
oh great
Donald Trump's next nft drop oh Perfecto
God damn it I'm excited if this is if
this is good I might have to buy a
couple we could turn Corridor into an
nft bro scam like like that you know
the original Donald Trump NFC collection
it's pretty hard to surpass the original
one already looks like AI yeah the
original already
looks so
super stressed
oh my final Masterpiece is upon us
[Laughter]
good job this is actually very good yeah
Nick unanimous I did it I finally won
was it just luck or was it actually
skill we're about to find out
photo of the winner of the world's
ugliest person contest if I come up in
these results
oh no I made a typo and it could this
could actually ruin I feel really mean
but
you gotta break some hearts
that's for the prompting
[Laughter]
I might be the one voted off but the
real loser
I just typed the ugliest person in the
world and I know they looked a lot like
Dean I don't know what happened it was
my birthday yesterday
it's a really bad way to kick off the
whole fresh Year of Living yeah whoever
wins this current round will be tied for
Dean in second place if they can win two
in a row Dean gets knocked out of the
championship who do you feel most
confident about going up against since
you have the most wins right now anyone
all right here we go wait what are my
kids playing with oh no oh no actually
that's kind of a good one
all right generate this
I want you to take me past the Border in
my mind which I will not cross on my own
I think I think I have something I would
like to go to sleep tonight
about a single image I don't know man I
don't think it's looking good oh no
that's pretty good I gotta go west it's
a tiny it's a little it's a kid tank but
this one is actually functional that's a
West Wind
all right and the Greek god of crypto
with a bunch of bfx artists well I guess
less isn't Beatrix artist but he's a
nerd get me those games dude bring me to
the Moon
[Applause]
[Music]
made it to the championship two and a
half minutes on the timer honestly it's
fun seeing everyone's art it's fun
making some here but I'm craving
something a little spicier I I'm craving
something that even shocks me with what
this AI generates you know I want to
cross these boundaries in my own mind
and this AI hopefully helps me at this
point it's time to let my fingers do the
talking uh you know being the office
Jackie Chan uh that was my first day at
Corridor I feel like I'm channeling that
energy once again I'm feeling good
Sam yeah hold it down hold it I will
don't worry I got you so this is the
championship round West has the second
most points Sam has the first most
points let's see if they can be funny
enough to take the crown no trap cards
in the championship just pure talent and
creativity here and the prompt is a
rendering of your opponent's mom
[Applause]
here we go
look at the concentration these
gentlemen have
what are some adjectives you guys would
include here Harry bumpy yo mama so big
you know bug
my mid journey is not not working
banned words
of just over 30 seconds left I'm seeing
a lot of a lot of sweat coming off our
prompters here but I'm not hearing a lot
of clacking that's usually a sign of a
good prompt and I'm just seeing frowns
up there no no just at that moment it
looks like this mid-journey maybe 10
seconds left
ah well I can't use mid-journey all
right here we go what will he do he's
down to only two AI softwares
winner takes off
I went for the Lloyd Christmas Dumb and
Dumber haircut here
the milk made on on old MacBook
you know what honestly I took
inspiration I did type swamp hag
[Laughter]
side of the line
such a story there are you in the
festival
Pottery I think it's clear that we do
have crowd favorite West
fund the very first ever slightly
offensive art contest that we've had
comes in here wins every freaking
challenge we give them yes yes
it's over I tried to get too deep in the
West's soul but I missed the audience's
soul
I lost thank you thank you honestly I
hope we can do this again so we can
Dethrone West if that's gonna happen no
no it's it's the office Jackie Chan in
me
everyone I have a very important
announcement hey have you seen our show
crew cuts if you like this video each
episode of crew cuts is basically just
like it it's the whole studio it's
getting together having a lot of fun
doing experiments coming up with wacky
ideas so head on over there right now
and check it out
okay that's perfect I don't know this is
perfect